so the question is why are all these
Muslims so riled up now these Muslim
parents obviously you can see they're
very very upset sorry the Christian
parents and other parents because
they're sending their children to school
to learn Reading Writing and math but at
the same time now their children are
being exposed to the pornographic
content explicit content if these books
were at the same time covering on 101
ways that a husband can have his wife
please excuse language an orgasm this
would also be something that the Muslims
Christians I'm sure would object to it's
one thing you're keeping your Private
Affairs in your bedroom to yourself and
now even if these were books were about
husband and wife action we would want
our children to be exposed to these
things so I want you to imagine if you
had an individual who came to a
children's park and that individual was
showing this book and all the explicit
content that it had in there to children
at the playground what would happen to
this individual you probably get charged
and arrested what difference is it if it
is by a teacher showing these explicit
things